previously on TV sins this is delicious
you read pieces for breakfast
show contains no opening scroll of
expositional backstory wait am i sitting
the show for not having a reading same
as Star Wars made that opening indelible
enough that its absence it's jarring
when you see a Star Destroyer on screen
up is down left is right dogs and cats
living together mass hysteria all the
shapes merging together looks great but
it makes no sense to have two ships
going in the opposite direction of the
fleet aesthetics over function ice in
the emperor has foreseen a new threat
rising against him the children of the
force it's good to see that Star Wars is
choosing to use the time-honored
tradition of bringing kids into the
franchise because that always brings the
audience back I'm really excited for the
next stage that cousin Oliver saga my
long-lost right sorry sorry not looking
for trouble how did he not feel this
incredibly important communication
device being removed from his belt was
it held on by a magnet if so how could
as Renault their lingo would be code
written instead of hey Jack weeds we
need backup at the quadrant baloney it's
your lucky day
knoefel scum you two come with us yeah
but you just called up to your bosses
and said I'm bringing in a citizen under
a charge of treason so how exactly will
you explain where he went if you'd just
said something like he didn't have a
permit or something I doubt anyone would
care but you said trees wait wait hey
kids got a even Fiza thief he's a
loveable thief and he'll still get a
beautiful woman by his side and make a
lot of important friends this is also
known as the Aladdin solution Sabine is
facing away from Kanan and I was fraught
to her zip has his eyes closed when the
light Pat signal happens this means the
signal is entirely dependent on hearing
Canaan's hand physically slap against
thigh fabric in the middle of a busy
street whose dumb idea was this and why
is anyone impressed thanks for doing the
heavy lifting holy s was annoying come
on man that wasn't even feigning effort
at least pretend you love your job big
guy catches you he'll end you
[Music]
these guys better question
are they skilled marksman who can take
out four bodies while speedily riding
through an alleyway or just lucky
because moments ago they couldn't shoot
a trooper five yards away the troopers
are frantically shooting a cargo they're
supposed to protect at all costs and
it's all fine because they're terrible
at shooting anything unless the plot
demands it also it's like the writer
said hey remember that great speed bike
scene in the forest and Return of the
Jedi let's do that but this time just
kidding made action sequence jokes
moment said no the cargo was shot and it
caused the kid to fly off course but now
it's suddenly fine how am I supposed to
be invested in a chase scene when
nothing really matters if Kanan catches
that kid I'm gonna end it he wants why
stop now and just a moment ago you
managed to leapfrog all the obstacles in
the street we're barely seven minutes
into the show and the plot conveniences
are raining down like bantha fodder
whatever is in these crates must really
be worth what out of the last seven
minutes of high-speed chases and gun
battles gave you that idea
nothing would thrill me more than
tossing you out well in flight man this
character Vinnie Jones are so hard I'm
half expecting Guy Ritchie to suit I'm
in space do you think the spacecraft was
going to cruise around the planet until
the bad guys got bored you don't get on
a boat and then act shocked when you
find yourself out in the open water I
mean it must be kind of nice to be able
to buy a pack of boxer briefs for a head
scarf it could signify this spark of
rebellion
next time they make a move we'll be
waiting for them to snuff out that spot
before it catches fire what was that I
was so distracted by this magneto helmet
beard that I lost my ability to
concentrate on the show I understand
that animation style is a choice but it
was really the right choice to make that
beard is clamping down on his jaw and
it's triggering my TMJ damn it
where'd they go if I told you I'd have
to kill you if I told you I'd have to
kill you cliche also Ezra totally sees
what's in these containers later on when
they feed the villagers so this threat
is extra bull lived on the phone my
whole life never been here The Imperials
don't advertise it
locals call it talking town it was
called district 9 at one point but then
an Earthling infatuated with hobbits and
elves decided to sue hobbits we got the
goods and took a bite out of the Empire
did you though not downplaying but you
stole a few guns some food and maybe
killed a few soldiers all things the
Empire could replace in the time it took
you to get to tarkintown how does no-one
ever burn the face off when they turn on
a lightsaber for the first time he
didn't even know what it was I know
you're not gonna believe me but it's
like this thing
wanted me to take it you're right I
don't believe you why don't we find out
Kanan is a Jedi he should absolutely
believe and know that as rahat enough of
the force in him for this statement to
be accurate also sending myself for the
fact that I know that was certainty he
tries anything sound the alarm
Oh shooting I'm at intense ends because
I'm tired of Zeb threatening Ezra and
not following through on it all bark and
no bite makes up a dull boy language
okay no kids are watching this show we
don't have time to take him home anyway
we need to move now I'll keep an eye on
him hey but what about the meaning he
just interrupted oh that wasn't
important it's a trap writers give a
classic Star Wars lined up as rap I'm
sending the bat of that finally we see
Zeb follow through on his Ezra hatred I
mean pushing him into gunfire it's
basically attempted murder and that may
be a little too far but at least there's
some character congruence I suppose I
should remove at least one of those
since I had it do it okay kid you
kidding
swimming motions to not propel you
forward in zero gravity idiot we're no
rookies same questions asked at the
final Return of the Jedi script reading
somehow made it into this episode they
just left out the end what the fray
walks sorry Jed he's not the whole thing
was a setup that's what I thought about
the prequels but they ended up being
actual Canon so you might need to double
check Kanan it's always mother to Jawas
for a couple credits the first hour of
this show seems to be people spouting
off alien names we've heard in all the
movies it's like they want to test out
their own version of CW bingo and you
can't have everything Disney and of
course the only thing I managed to hold
on to was this worthless piece of
of course the guards just happen to miss
the easily accessible chunky cubes
trapped somewhere on your back
this is master obi-wan Kenobi are we the
only ones that can hear the hollow be
speak I arising to take oh now you'll
hear 10 seconds in and you just now hear
they'll be waiting for us we can't save
him and honestly why should you even one
tear he tried to steal from you and then
eventually he actually does steal from
you if this video hasn't gotten to the
cross yet Ezra sucks
Ezra the strolling around the enemy ship
and accidentally in his weight of his
belongings next thing you know he'll
stumble upon a game-changing piece of
information
the transport ship agent Kallus diverted
would duck on Kessel within two hours I
guess I can buy the convenience of the
helmet being tuned into the right
frequency but I'm not fine the
convenience that better than Ezra put it
on just at the right moment to hear all
their plans Thank You Beth you're
wearing a massive helmet designed to
protect the head from damage I don't
understand how that could have hurt but
I'm glad it did
oh the old storm troopers to converge on
the lower hangar I'll meet them there
this is trooper LS one two three
reporting intruders in the upper hangar
sir I believe the lower hangar as a
diversion
Ezra's either stupid lucky at lingo and
trooper tech or he has acquired serious
knowledge in his short life I don't know
if the show gets around to explaining
this but for now it's a distraction
and annoying and this time try not to
leave until everyone's back aboard that
was not my fault it was the shield how
is he even still here to even give that
order he's holding on to nothing
he should be space sucked already this
is the area where they exploded the ship
just a bit ago and it should be
absolutely dump have you heard of the
spice mines of Kessel
slaves sent there last a few months
maybe a year and four wookies born in
the forest it's a death sentence but it
sounds like it's a death sentence no
matter what race you are considering you
only last a year at most I'm not gonna
tell these rebels how to prioritize
their missions but why haven't they set
their sights on the mines before now
here's an idea
open the ramp directly in front of a
squad of enemies who will shoot directly
at us no no don't stay on the ship and
use our massive firepower to destroy
anyone in our way
leaping directly into danger is the best
way all these people should be dead okay
Oh God good guys shooting bad guys die
bad guys shooting good guys don't die
the end Freddie Prinze Jedi both
troopers focus your fire on on the Jedi
but they were already doing that and
they were horrible at it Ezra catches up
with baby looking in stormtrooper so
quickly then I can't help but wonder
what the hell they've been doing in the
two minutes since they ran from the
battle
we'll helmet screen look I'm just
talking Oh boss baby baby geniuses Who
Framed Roger Rabbit
well sorry thought we were naming movies
where babies could talk so I guess you
drop me off next yeah finally right
right this will they or won't they drunk
a mouthful is annoying and pointless
this is a pilot where we know Ezra is
the main character and therefore we know
he ends up sticking with this crew and
fighting alongside them for many seasons
to come so why not build up some
suspense somewhere it's actually
warranted an agent Kallus you did well
to call
was this supposed to mean something to
me or do I need to watch seven seasons
of another show to understand what that
means because if that's the case then
you Star Wars rebels q so hard I can't
breathe in this thing let me see your
identification you don't need to see his
identification careful you'll shoot your
eye out kid come on to the coast we get
together have a few laughs